do you by the way think about
ai and the existential threats like
speaking of gods
are you is this whole technological
world we talked about social networks
and this
increasing power of technology around us
we ourselves are becoming less human
because we keep becoming
we we keep relying on technology more
and more
so we're becoming kinds of cyborgs but
also there's a future that's
quite possible where the technology
becomes
smarter and more powerful than us humans
and you know starts
having a life of its own in ways that
perhaps we don't imagine as human beings
i don't just mean like
two-legged robots walking around and
being humans but smarter
i mean like an intelligent life that's
that's beyond and
uh fundamentally different than our
human life it's
it's infinite it's uh also creating a
new species yeah
yeah a new a new kind of species not
even just a new species we talk about
systems but like
it it lives in the space of information
it lives
uh in a different time scale in a
different scale also a spatial scale
it uh operate like we speak we spoke
about individuals it doesn't operate in
the sense of a single individual like it
embodied it's not embodied so it's not
like a thing that walks around and
it like it looks at stuff it consumes
the world it's able to do
much larger scale sensing of the
environment around it
all that kind of stuff i can't barely
even try to i can barely even conceive
of what that would be like are you
scared are you excited
i don't define like scared or excited i
feel like i try and tend to define them
like the same
way or i'm like i guess i
i'm kind of like before karaoke that's
the same
well that's actually kind of my happy
place it's not so much everyone else's
you know it's uh everyone else is
probably you know heading for the door
at that point but you know it's uh while
you're doing it or leading
or leading up to the karaoke system well
it depends whether or not uh whether or
not they know it's me
if they know it's me that's before i
start if they as they're like who's that
guy then they're like halfway through
the song they're already
throwing their beer what category is a
song or a particular song are we talking
about in terms of like your happy place
oh man are you kidding me i mean
obviously behemoth rhapsody i mean
there's no question because
oh yeah because i don't have to sing it
here it's that it's like you remember
can you can i be oh yeah of course is he
here no
yeah then yeah yeah all right if you i
like this i hear no that i can't i've a
torn i've uh
i have torn feelings about my human
rhapsody because i like the beginning
part the sadness i like like the solo
the heartbreak but the second part i
understand it is so
just like it gets ridiculous it's so
ridiculous it ruins it for me but it's
more about flexing on people i think if
you can actually
hit hit that hit that you're the
falsetto yeah
so it's it's not okay so you appreciate
enough for the musical
uh beauty and complexity of the song you
just like to flex on board because like
for all yeah like what's the purpose of
anything except for just to let everyone
know that you think you're cool
and there's no better way of doing that
than karaoke so i'm not sure why about
karaoke audience yeah exactly oh fear
and excitement of artificial
intelligence i mean like you know me i
don't know anything about
i just i i basically i don't i don't
understand the implications of
any of this i would just say that like
radically altering what it means to be
human in such an unbelievably short
period of time just seems like
such a crazy thing and also it's not
like we're i can't remember who said
this to me recently
like i can't remember so this is
definitely not my idea but uh
we're we're not even going hey would you
like to opt in
everyone everyone is being opted in
you know and particularly when you want
to talk about like large-scale robotics
or large-scale ai like the world is
changing people in
senegal are opting in right now without
realizing it it's not even like in the
end i don't mean to pick on senegal it's
just whatever country comes up to mind
but
it's in the developing world but
basically uh you know
recognizing that this huge shift is
coming
we have no idea this is a decent idea
and also something else i've always been
considered
is uh you know you think about most of
the really awful
awful awful things that have done in
history large-scale slavery
holly you name it it didn't if people
say that it came from
this motivation or that motivation maybe
it did maybe it didn't fundamentally the
issue at least in my mind
i'm not a historian power differential
if you if you and i can't contest we
don't contend it's not like you we fight
and you might win or we fight even
you'll win comfortably
it's you are so unbelievably powerful
compared to me that there's nothing i
can do to stop you
that seems like a recipe for something
really really not great happening
because if you think about like uh
you know european countries encountering
each other and i'm just speculating i
don't know anything about history but
let's say countries that can contend
with one another
versus countries that can't
let's say an alien species alien race
shows up you know right now we don't
want that i think stephen hawking said
that it makes for
it makes perfect sense to me we don't
want that if you can come here
we better hope you're nice because what
are we going to do what are we going to
hope that you invade the water planet
like they did in uh you know one of the
uh
side lord of the year where the world so
i guess what i'm trying to get across is
like
shocking levels of power differential
between groups seem makes that makes the
world ripe
for horrific abuse in the event that
someone decides to do it
it's like like you imagine an adult
hating a child like hating hitting a
child no one in their right mind would
ever go like okay that's a great idea
because it's such an it's so grossly
imbalanced you're like this is
wrong but but it's also on the table
only because of the gross imbalance
so i guess to come back it's like
whether we create ai
and it's on some crazy level of its own
or it's
i'm in charge of it or so i just it
seems like we're
we're creating you mentioned like uh
game theory
and nuclear war what prevented nuclear
war i mean i
presumably mutually assure destruction i
mean hopefully also humanity
and the humanity and the the reasonable
you know cooler heads prevailing and
going
hey i can i can understand the veil of
ignorance and i um i don't go oh yeah
let me kill those guys because i can i
go this is wrong period
and in concept this is not an action i
should take
but it's also nice and easy to keep me
honest if i know that i can't get you
without being got myself
yeah but what happens when i can get
anyone
anything and i'm more or less
untouchable like that seems to me to be
like
like various times in colonial history
you know what i mean and
what happened we know what happened but
so the possibility
of really bad things are
plentiful possibilities but are the
possibilities of
really positive things applying for like
what though i'm not saying wrong i don't
know
so i can give a million examples one is
just the examples of the parent and the
child
uh you said uh there's a power
differential
there and we don't like
a parent hitting their child what about
not just hitting like
beating like really yeah great beating
their child
how often percentage-wise do you see
that happening even though that
that that uh power differential first of
all
other people's kids let's just put this
on the table
i love kids but other people's kids can
be annoying sometimes
sometimes you got to deal out some
justice i get it
but we don't practice we don't take
advantage of that power differential
no so like there is ethics there's
moralities that emerge
that allow the power differential to be
used for good versus for bad
so like you're one of the assumptions
with stephen hawking or with uh
if russia became much more powerful than
america or america much more
powerful than russia in the cold war
your assumption that immediately
that power differential not your
assumption but it would express itself
right would express itself
in the in the same way that it was
trying to express itself when there was
a more
uh level competition but it's also
possible when the power differential
grows
the incentive the joy whatever the
mechanisms that
uh made sense when it was at the same
level
the the incentives become very different
it's not as fun to destroy the ant
colony
you start becoming more the kind of a
conservationist
like one hopes that's an evolved
perspective though yeah
well i don't know if it's evolved or not
but it's definitely a possibility it's
unclear to me
that something that's many orders of
magnitude more powerful than us
will want to destroy us well i mean what
did we
what did i mean how did how did mass
slavery occur how did
you know like just big dogs playing with
not
i think i think slavery and
a lot of the atrocities in history
happened when the power differential was
not as great
as as we're talking about with ai
potentially
is that not somehow worse than that's
not obvious to me it's not obvious that
things that are way more powerful that
that's fair
okay so i think i i think you're i guess
how do you restrain it though
uh there there's a lot of different
discussions of how to
uh i assume restraining each other
because let's say i go and decide to
strike someone's child which i'd like to
think i wouldn't do
yes i will be promptly i will find
myself in front of a judge
and so i feel like there's a lot can you
imagine how many people usually get
murdered
just in the woods yeah i mean i would
just presume it's a lot
you know and i don't think most people
are lunatics like that but i would just
say
that's the point if you're given though
if you're given to that your ability to
get away with it
was was greater in the past because a
chance of detection was less
so that doesn't allow you yeah this is
what that's called an artificial
intelligence ai safety research
called value alignment of ensuring as
you build
the the systems that become smarter and
smarter and more powerful and powerful
make sure that their values are aligned
with the entities
over which they're becoming powerful
with humans so if you were to talk to an
ai that's becoming smarter at first it's
dumber than unit but it's becoming
smarter and smarter
you have to create mechanisms
where you both value the same things i
guess one thing i wonder
so i guess i'm i'm probably not like
sharp enough to grasp this if i'm honest
but i guess like i wonder like uh
i use the chess programs um you know was
deep blue
stock fish and then like alpha zero and
alpha zero teaching itself to beat
stock fish without any help in four
hours yeah yeah like it becomes
orders of magnitude more intelligence
than us ineffectively
an instantaneous period i guess what i
always wondered like uh
if you were that much smarter than me
i feel like your ability to manipulate
me would be pretty significant or at
least potentially no
but manipulation
implies that the incentive is to
overpower
everything around you like there's
implied incentives
if your value is to actually
like uh it depends what you want in life
okay what you want in your system like
it's it's not clear
that the goal of an ai system that's
all-powerful is to destroy all humans no
i don't think that i don't think that it
is either i guess what i'm even enslave
all humans
i that's fair i guess what i'm trying to
suggest is that
something adequately powerful these
these actions are on the table
yes they're on the table and that's
scary and that's why a lot of people are
really concerned about it and are
working on it i'm just trying to make
the case
for agi because if they're watching this
he's the one to kill uh no actually i
was thinking i was uh
yeah i i i watched toilets like
really well there's there's no i mean
that that's the main concern for all the
people in the aictu research
people talk about agis it's
uh it's kind of disturbing how little
people
are working on trying to
create mechanisms that keep ai's values
aligned with ours
that's completely unshocking yeah we
we humans seem to do only good when like
you know you even look at like
coronavirus it's like when
yeah like the water has to be leaking
from the ceiling
you have to be there fine fine blood
everywhere fire
just destruction we just seem to ignore
completely and writing all over the wall
riding all over the wall
you